watching the Valley's most accurate
forecast on 8 news now well there's a
chance they could get a dusting yet this
afternoon but I don't think it'll be
accumulating to a whole lot lots going
on different weather just depends on
where you are here we are looking from
near the spaghetti Bowl across the strip
at the Strat some blue sky but
definitely some storm clouds around 47's
the official temperature out at Reed we
always like to check in on your
neighborhoods everybody in the 40s and
you really should not expect a whole lot
warmer the entire week we're going to be
seeing high temperatures struggling to
reach 50 28 right now up at Kyle Canyon
wind not really a factor upwards of a
quarter of an inch of rain yesterday in
that steady pitter patter generally less
than a tenth of an inch all over town
and it's all gone meantime to Nevada and
Beyond not even 60 for Death Valley over
the hunt and prep you're at 42 and
winter storm watches continue for Cedar
City and Caliente you guys up in Lincoln
County may be getting more of a dusting
of snow this afternoon possibly an
accumulation of an inch or three
meantime we're going for all of 49 today
not quite 10 degrees below normal low
this morning 35 some neighborhoods
scraping near the freezing Mark that's
why we wanted to bring up the three p's
we're talking about protecting your pets
your pipes and your plants if you don't
think the little cats and doggies can
handle the chill bring them indoors for
your pipes if you think they might
freeze wrap them or let them drip a
little bit if you got plants that you
want to survive cover with a cloth and
some people add a couple of other peas
people make sure you check on friends
and pools you want to have your pool
cover working okay so here we are with
this low pressure system wrapping up
Western Colorado is getting snow while
Denver right now is warmer than we are
for your family and friends we are just
going to continue to track this blizzard
as it moves to the East and may turn
into tornado watches across the Deep
South so lots to keep an eye on over the
next few days meantime temperatures
looking like this 29 up in North Dakota
41 in Chicago here's your most accurate
day forecast we are talking about
staying in the upper 40s all week long
Hanukkah begins on Sunday evening
overnight lows though are going to be
flirting with the freezing Mark Heather
so make sure you bundle up in the
overnight and early morning hours indeed
that is chilly Nate thank you